up and down the country postal workers
have begun a 48-hour walkout over paying
conditions impacting this Black Friday
shopping weekend let's speak to Dave
Ward should we General Secretary of the
CWU communication Workers Union of
course hi Dave good to see you thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning I'm guessing you've timed the
strike for now to have Maximum Impact
with Black Friday
well I think okay we we've got to be
honest here that postal workers who are
only 18 months ago were being held as
key workers for keeping the country
connected during the pandemic and now
facing the most brutal attack on jobs
that we've seen in this country for
decades what's going on and I really do
wish that people could look into what's
actually taking place in not what the
company is saying the truth is that this
company is axing thousands upon
thousands of jobs
it's at the same time replacing decent
postal workers by refusing to lay off 11
000 agency workers and recruit in new
self-employed drivers and new workers on
almost 20 percent less terms and
conditions this is outrageous behavior
and the company itself is also
destroying Royal Mail as we know it they
have no intention of continuing Royal
Mail one of the most iconic British
companies that are that is a round they
are destroying it they want to turn it
into just another parcel Courier and I'm
going to say to you today the people who
are running this company have got so
much to answer for the the levels of
harassment and intimidation and threats
that are going on in workplaces every
day would be unacceptable in in any
business and yet it's the leaders of the
company who are doing this to Ordinary
Decent postal workers and we're not
going to put up with us we cannot accept
what they're doing we don't want to be
on strike we want to reach an agreement
we want to serve the communities that
our members have been doing for years
and years and I just wish that the
government would really look at this I
think this is getting bigger now than
just a dispute about our members jobs
terms and conditions no company should
be allowed to leave a group of workers
and a service so popular as Royal Mail
in the way that they're doing
okay what sort of threats have your
members been subjected to
well I suggest that you speak to postal
I'm speaking to you Dave you made the
allegations right yeah yeah yeah no okay
I'm making the allegation because it
threats about micromanaging people every
day telling them when they've got to
work when they can't work threatening
them if they bring Mal back because
there's quality of service failures that
they'll be sacked so they're trying to
put pressure on people to work beyond
the time they're being paid uh just
speak to postal workers they'll they'll
say I've seen women postal workers
recently resigning
um because saying that their mental
health is being affected by the leader
of this company who spends all of his
time on his workplace social media
platform almost at war with his own
workers there's no CEO in the in the
world that would behave in that way and
be allowed to get away with it and this
is such a serious dispute now you know
we're calling on the public to
understand what we want is real
modernization we want modernization
looks going to work for customers for
the future of the business and for our
members this is not what we're facing
this is an asset stripping plan it's a
leveling down okay and I don't know what
this country is coming to if this is the
way that that workers are going to
continue to be treated let me take you
back to my initial question if I may
please um Dave and that was about you've
timed this for Maximum Impact on Black
Friday haven't you and I can understand
why you've done that but what would you
say to those businesses who are trying
to get themselves back on their feet and
they're absolutely relying on things
like Black Friday in order for their
business to recover after the pandemic
I would say to them that we've got no
choice and what they should be doing is
posing those questions to the company
who were only out last week facing the
market and this is what this is about as
well they face the market and say the
business is in a sound place got a great
asset Base Great balance sheet and then
they come to us and say they're running
out of cash and we will be bankrupt in
three months somebody needs to look into
this this is not the fault of postal
workers people know postal workers want
to want to be serving the public serving
businesses but we cannot accept this
level of attack so you know there's no
other alternative for us at this point
in time okay
um the company is saying you've been
offered nine percent over 18 months and
there is no more offer on the table and
there isn't going to be 99 over 18
months sounds like a pretty good deal to
some I'm guessing
okay if there was an offer on the table
with nine percent over 18 months that
was back dated uh so that our members
got the full value of that and it was
linked to real modernization we wouldn't
be standing there today we would have
accepted that offer that's not what's on
the table and I'll come back to the
point about the level of job losses that
are going on I mean ask anybody why
would you sack postal workers in the
numbers that they're sacking at the
moment and at the same time retain 11
000 agency workers and Recruit new
workers self-employed workers and
workers on 20 less pay terms and
conditions is somebody going to suggest
to us that we should accept that would
any worker in the country accept that
would would the government accept that
is that how you grow the economy these
things have got to be challenged now on
a higher level than just us fighting for
our members jobs and decent postal
workers fighting for their jobs the
government need to intervene in this I
don't think it's any coincidence Kate
that the the chairman of Royal Mail is
also the guy who wrote the report on the
railways uh the same people and we
genuinely feel that there's a
coordinated approach here to attacking
workers who are just standing up for for
their jobs their pay their terms and
conditions we want modernization we've
agreed that the thing that Romel really
wanted was one parcel Network we've
actually agreed that during the week we
said to him we're willing to agree that
but they just relentlessly they want to
start people three hours later what
company that delivers Parcels letters
and packets says to its Workforce we're
going to start you three three hours
later and we're gonna we're gonna grow
this business it's not about that uh
Dave we're out of time but thanks can I
say something to you tomorrow we're on
strike we're on strike tomorrow okay I
know get get Simon Thompson in the
studio with me and we'll debate this
yeah
yeah okay that's what your colleagues
think of it um I can certainly say that
we've got one of the bosses of uh Royal
Mail on Ian King live uh from 10 o'clock
so do stay tuned for more on that